bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat hier les sénateurs ont adopté le
projet de loi relatifs au développement
économique de l'outre-mer
l'ump et les centristes ont voté pour le
parti socialiste s'est abstenu et le
groupe communiste a voté contre ce texte
le groupe rdse a partagé son vote entre
l'abstention et le vote pour ce matin je
vous propose de revoir la discussion
portant sur l'article 20 sur la question
du logement social dans les dom
avec l'amendement déposé par la
sénatrice anne marie payet sur le
logement social en faveur des personnes
âgées
bonne séance à tous al marri payet le
387 rectifié bis oui monsieur le
président cet article 20 créer un
nouveau dispositif de défiscalisation en
faveur du logement social outre-mer en
les besoins sont également très
importants en matière de logements
destinés à héberger les personnes âgées
en conséquence cet amendement vise à
étendre le dispositif mis en place pour
cet article à destination des
investisseurs qui souhaitent contribuer
à la construction de logements pour
personnes âgées pourraient en bénéficier
les personnes modestes de plus de 65 ans
les prestations d'hébergement rendu aux
personnes âgées pourrait s'accompagner
de prestation de services adaptés à leur
situation sans qu'il s'agisse pour
autant de maisons médicalisées et
le rapporteur c'est le présidentialisme
mes chers collègues la commission on l'a
déjà dit il n'est pas favorable par
principe à l'extension des dispositifs
de défiscalisation du logement en
outre-mer par ailleurs cette extension
ici aurait un coût qui n'est pas
chiffrée certainement important
toutefois elle reconnaît la nécessité de
prendre des mesures en faveur des
logements pour personnes âgées dans les
dom et relève que l'extension proposée
maintiendrez la condition de ressources
des personnes âgées locataires à
conséquent elle s'en remet à la sagesse
du sénat
alors monsieur le ministre
partagez vous ce point de vue on ne peut
pas en face à tant de sagesse ne pas les
gouvernements proposent aussi s'en remet
aussi à la sagesse qu il espérera
positif du sénat sur cette affaire le
gage élèves le gage évidemment si le
sénat donne suite à cette demande de
sagesse positive et bien écouté devant
tant de sagesse positif qui est pour
adopter l'amendement d'anne marie payet
écoutez il est adopté à l'unanimité
trois amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune anne marie payet
nous poursuivons d'ailleurs trois
amendements identiques
le bail est le virapoullé et le mars 1
oui le seul président cet amendement est
un amendement de précision qui concerne
la notion de programmes immobiliers
introduite pour les opérations de
défiscalisation des logements sociaux
il s'agit principalement de préciser que
ces programmes devront avoir une
proportion minimale de logements sociaux
exprimé en surface voilà jean paul
virapoullé s'est défendu et puis daniel
marsin s'est défendu quel est l'avis de
monsieur le rapporteur à l'émanation
merci monsieur le président je me sens
portée par la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement semble permettre de
rendre le dispositif de type de
défiscalisation en matière de logement
social plus opérationnel et plus
facilement contre la par
l'administration sous réserve de la
confirmation qu apportera je suppose de
gouvernement la commission est favorable
à l'amendement et aux deux autres
évidemment alors aux seuls ministres
écoutez ces trois amendements sont
visionnaires efficace et nous ne pouvons
être que favorable élevé le gage au
repos de gages avis unanime de d'autres
assemblées les trois amendements sont
adoptés
merci alors c'est notre collègue tué
yava qui nous présente le 138 c'est
richard williams a mis le président
smith mes chers collègues je sais très
bref c'est un moment précision est
quelque peu quelque part de mise en
cohérence
la référence exclusive effectivement des
décrets d'application pour la
détermination des plafonds de ressources
à part est insatisfaisante dans le cas
de la rédaction actuelle du quatrième
alinéa du pain du grand 2 de l'article
20 insatisfaisant effectivement pour les
collectivités d'outre-mer qui relèvent
de l'article 74 de la constitution ainsi
que la nouvelle calédonie et quand vient
en effet de confier la tâche de
déterminer ses plates formes de
ressources pardon aux autorités locales
compétentes
les gars au statut particulier de ces
collectivités et c'est effectivement
très de magna très vigoureuse que
vêtements je revendique en tant que
parlementaire d'une de ces collectivités
le statut d'autonomie qu on ne pouvant
en bénéficier
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président de celle
mise mais chacun qui nous paraît
difficile de laisser libre les
collectivités d'outre-mer de déterminer
les critères de ressources ayant un
impact pour l'application du dispositif
de défiscalisation et donc pour les
finances publiques
il revient donc dans notre esprit à
l'état de fixer par décret l'ensemble
des paramètres donc l'avis est
défavorable
c'est le même point de vue monsieur le
ministre deux avis défavorable sur cet
amendement clé pour l'adopter
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adoptée gaston flosse de 230 afin d'
éviter l'obsolescence des plafonds de
loyer il ya lieu de prévoir leur
actualisation chaque année à londres de
l'évolution de l'indicé du coût de la
vie dans chaque collectivité
cette disposition s'inspire de celle qui
prévaut la détermination du plafond du
montant de la réduction d'impôt en
fonction du coût de la construction vide
monsieur le rapporteur
c'est le président avis défavorable il
ne se
ne nous semble pas pertinent d'indexer
les plafonds de ressources sur le coût
de la vie ce qui empêcherait toute
modulation futur des paramètres de
financement donc un avis défavorable
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
adopter cet amendement qui est contre il
n'est pas adopté six amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
jean paul virapoullé
alors ça c'est un petit amendement de
précisions il a pour but d'abord de
renvoyer un décret la base éligibles
avantage fiscal
et puis le corrige une erreur matérielle
et précise la rédaction du texte et
monsieur et daniel marsin avait présenté
le même
il est défendu merci anne marie payet le
370 oui monsieur le président c'est un
amendement rédactionnelle kick
originaire de référence merci d'avoir vu
cette erreur ensuite le 357 rectifié
deux amendements identiques elles 366
elle 254 qui suivra est très proche
alors c'est anne marie payet le 357
rectifier
oui monsieur président l'article 20
étant notamment le dispositif de
défiscalisation des investissements
productifs au logement social
or les opérations de logement locatif
social programmé au titre de la nba qui
seront visés par un montage en
défiscalisation doivent correspond à une
même définition des dépenses éligibles à
l'assiette de défiscalisation que les
autres sous peine de créer deux régimes
de base éligibles et rendre très
complexe le montage de ces opérations
cet amendement vise la reprise des
dépenses aujourd'hui éligibles à un
financement lb eu dans la base éligibles
au programme locatifs sociaux en
défiscalisation
merci daniel marsin je considère qu'il
est présenté défendu
merci et c'est jacques gillot qui nous
présente 254 aussi il est défendu
alors ma passion au sud rapporteur vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues alors l'avis de la
commission est favorable à l'amendement
de monsieur virapoullé donc celui de
monsieur marin et on suggère à madame
payet de retirer son amendement au
profit des amendements 276 et 364 qui
sont dans la rédaction et plus clair en
ce qui concerne le 357
l'objectif de cet amendement sans être
de mieux articuler le recours conjoint
aux deux dispositifs de la libérer et de
la défiscalisation pour les opérations
de logement social en évitant la
référence à deux bases éligibles
différentes son dispositif semble
toutefois difficilement opérant par
ailleurs ces définitions relève
actuellement du décret et nous
sollicitons l'avis du gouvernement sur
le 360
6 c'est le même donc le gouvernement et
tous et le 250 4t très proches et nous
sollicitons aussi l'avis du gouvernement
ministre 176 nous émettons un avis
favorable sur le 364 un avis favorable
nous sollicitons aussi madame payet pour
qu'elle retire le 370 dont la rédaction
semble moins claire que les deux
précédents et vous le retire le 370
s'est retiré et sur les trois suivants
puisque c'est le même le même type
évidemment le gouvernement est sensible
aux préoccupations légitimes qu'ils sont
qui sont exprimés dans ces amendements
mais comme cela été remarqués fort
justement par la commission il ya un
risque d'incohérence donc nous sommes
malheureusement défavorable à ces trois
événements merci monsieur le ministre
alors sur les 276 et 364 identique le
virapoullé le mars un quai pour
l'adopter qui est pour et qui est contre
ils sont adoptés et les autres tombes
voilà le 357 rectifier le 366 et le
254,4 amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune georges patient a
annoncé richard tout est mia va qui nous
présente le 417 jeu président le
ministre en chef au legs
ces amendements visent à supprimer les
obligations d'information de demande
d'agrément auprès du ministre du budget
préalablement à toute opération de
défiscalisation
en effet ces démarches constitue un
obstacle à la bonne réalisation de ces
opérations en entraînant leur blocage
par ailleurs le ministre du budget
disposent déjà d'informations relatives
à ces opérations qui lui permettent
effectivement d'avoir qu'on connaissance
de ces investissements merci alors le
c'est jacques gillot qui nous le
présente ici président
cet amendement vise à relever le seuil
du montant en capital des sociétés qui
vont faire l'objet d'investissements
aussi dû pour des programmes de logement
social en défiscalisation
en effet la loi le projet de loi limite
le plafond capital de ces sociétés à un
million d'euros
au delà de ce seuil un agrément
préalable doit être obtenues du
ministère chargé du budget or le seuil
de millions d'euros limite le nombre de
logements possibles à 7 ou 10 logements
ce qui est faible au regard de la
complexité de ces montages
aussi est-il demandé que le soldat
vraiment se reporter à 4,6 millions
d'euros ceux de la loi de
défiscalisation actuelle afin de relever
le nombre de logements correspondant de
7 ou 8 ans une trentaine par opération
sans passer par une demande d'agrément
préalable disposition trop lourde pour
relancer la production de logements
sociaux
si anne marie payet a sauté présenter le
même
il est défendu et daniel marsin c'est
exactement le même
il est défendu merci alors quelle est la
vie sur ces quatre amendements de
monsieur le rapporteur éric doligé merci
monsieur le président donc vous changez
de poulain devient heureux donc sur ces
quatre amendements bien on a un avis
globalement défavorable pour la raison
suivante sur le premier qui vise à
supprimer l'obligation de notification
des opérations défiscalisation vous
savez que cette obligation nous l'avions
ajoutée au niveau de la commission des
finances et j'avais expliqué tout à
l'heure pour quelles raisons donc
défavorable pour les trois autres qui
sont identiques vous souhaitez relever
de 1 à 4 6 millions d'euros le seuil à
partir duquel les opérations de
défiscalisation en matière de logement
social peuvent obtenir un agrément donc
l'obtention d'un agrément bien sûr ce
n'est pas la remise en cause de
l'opération mais c'est simplement la
volonté que nous avons de bien connaître
les opérations et bien sûr souhaitable
que ces opérations soient très vite
traité au niveau de l'administration
pour ne pas ralentir les différentes
opérations donc on a un avis défavorable
sur les trois amants et monsieur le
ministre
concernant le 417 c'est un avis
défavorable proche pour la même raison
que ceux de la commission sur les trois
suivants c'est aussi un avis défavorable
mais j'ai une grande nouvelle une bonne
nouvelle à vous annoncer
puisque nous ne changerons pas le seuil
d'agrément mais par contre nous
changeons le seuil de l'examen local
jusqu'à présent les dossiers étaient
examinés au ministère en administration
centrale
au-delà d'1 5 million d'euros le
gouvernement va porter ce seuil à 10
millions d'euros
c'est à dire que tous les dossiers de
moins de 10 millions d'euros
nécessiteront un agrément mais un examen
locales ce qui devrait accélérer très
largement les programmes et répondent à
vos préoccupations
ce qui devrait même peut-être vous
permettre de retirer ces amendements ses
préoccupations étant largement couverte
par cette annonce bien alors nous en
revenons au à l'amendement de notre
collègue patient qui est pour l'adopter
il y a deux avis défavorables qui est
contre il n'est pas adoptée et les 316
356 rectifier et le 365 alors l' annonce
faite par le ministre de relever à 10
millions d'euros
est-ce que cela vous engage a retiré ses
amendements
ce gillot il est retiré
anne marie payet il est retiré et daniel
marsin vous prenez cela en fait comme
une bonne nouvelle donc ces trois
amendements sont retirés merci monsieur
le ministre
alors jean etienne antoinette le 23 il
est défendu seul ministre elle fait le
rapporteur
il a été bien défendu mais
malheureusement l'avis est défavorable
puisque l'extension la défiscalisation
que vous avez proposé chers collègues
par cet amendement nous paraît peu
opérante est trop large pour recevoir un
accueil de la commission accueil positif
le ministre partage ce point de vue deux
avis défavorables
y at il une demande d'explications de
vote
qui est pour adopter l'amendement de
jean etienne antoinette pour qui et
contre il n'est pas adopté ensuite nous
avons un amendement présenté par le
gouvernement le 4 146 amendement
présenté par le gouvernement est en fait
la reprise de l'amendement 139 de
jacques gillot qui nous semblait être un
eelam un amendement tout à fait justifié
et puis qui acheta buggé dans le dans le
dispositif et l'évolution de la
défiscalisation vers la production de
logement social obéit à une logique
celle de mettre à la disposition des
opérateurs sociaux de logement plus de
ressources pour remplir leur mission le
mode opératoire la défiscalisation doit
être neutre fiscalement pendant les cinq
années de portage des logements par le
véhicule fiscale les mêmes conditions de
tva et de tfpb doivent être appliquées
c'est donc en reprenant l'amendement
déposé par messieurs les sénateurs
gillot et repentin afin d'adapter les
dispositions du code général des impôts
relatif à la taxe foncière sur les
propriétés bâties pour garantir que
l'exonération de taxe foncier bâti pour
les logements sociaux s'appliquent
également aux nouveaux dispositifs de
défiscalisation et de modifier les
dispositions relatives à la tva pour qui
épate frottements fiscale comme on dit
en termes savants et donc le
gouvernement non seulement était
favorable aux amendements des honorables
parlementaires mais les reprend à son
compte pour qu'ils ne disparaissent pas
et qu'ils soient réintroduits dans la
législation
voilà encore un volonté de consensus
encore exprimés par ce geste et voilà un
ministre qui tient sa parole c'est très
bien bon
excusez moi monsieur le ministre quel
est l'avis de la commission
écoutez nous étions très favorable à
l'amendement 139 et nous l'avions
trouvée très grande qualité nous avions
été très triste de le voir disparaître
et le gouvernement nous fait la joie de
le réintroduire donc bien évidemment on
y est très favorable bien
qui donc adoptent cet amendement
gouvernemental d'origine gillot qui est
pour
eh bien écoutez il est adopté à
l'unanimité
merci monsieur le ministre deux
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
les amendements très proche le 380,4 de
daniel marsin oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à autoriser les
conseils généraux à exonérer la cession
des logements sociaux organismes hlm
prévues par le dispositif de
défiscalisation en matière de logement
social que qui fait l'objet de la loi
que nous sommes en train d'étudier en
effet l'article 20 du présent projet de
loi met en place un dispositif de
défiscalisation spécifiques afin de
favoriser la construction de logements
sociaux dans les départements
d'outre-mer ce dispositif prévoit que
les organismes hlm loup les logements
sociaux pendant cinq ans et au terme de
ces cinq années
ces logements leur sont rétrocédés ou
céder cet amendement vise donc à
permettre aux conseils généraux s'ils le
souhaitent d'exonérer de taxe de
publicité foncière ou de droits
d'enregistrement
cette session lorsque c'est top ses
doigts sont applicables ceci afin de
favoriser l'opération merci serge
larcher
il est défendu il est défendu
monsieur le rapporteur
positif qui vient nous est présentée
monsieur le président sur le ministre
est un dispositif qui nous paraît
intéressant puisqu'il est non compensés
par l'état et qui n'a pas de coût donc
pour l'état et qu'en plus il ya il donne
la liberté aux collectivités donc à ce
double titre
on a donné un avis favorable voilà deux
amendements au fait 1 est le gage élevé
une seule ministre
bien vite sur sur la vie mais c'est la
sagesse que le gouvernement propose à
l'assemblée évidemment si l'assemblée le
vote ils devraient le gage remercie
alors sagesse du gouvernement alors jean
claude frécon vous avez la parole
monsieur le président chers collègues je
m'interroge simplement sur la deuxième
partie de l'amendement de monsieur marc
st qu'ils aient repris en deuxième
partie de 384 qui est d'ailleurs repris
mais pas tout à fait avec la même
rédaction par le deuxième partie des
amendements 325 où on parle de la
compensation de cette perte de recettes
mais comme il s'agit des collectivités
locales ne doit-on pas laisser aux
collectivités locales le soin de
compenser comme elles veulent et si elle
en a envie il n'y avait pas obligation
j'allais dire de de cette compensation
oui c'est le gage malgache par rapport
aux dépenses de l'état mais papa mais
pas par rapport aux dépenses des
collectivités assez formel merci
monsieur le président votre réponse jean
claude frécon alors le larcher a été
rendu identique au premier
on considère qu'il irait et nous avons
un avis favorable de la commission une
sagesse du gouvernement je souviens
l'approbation ces deux amendements qui
est pour les adopter bien écouté ils
sont adoptés à l'unanimité
deux amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune jean etienne
antoinette feu doux présenté le 22
mon profil de celui de colette gilot 22
et retiré au profit de celui présenté
par jacques gillot le 330 de rectifier
cet amendement concerne la
défiscalisation de l'impôt sur les
sociétés défini par l'article 217
undecies du cgi et vise le même objet
que l'amendement nîmes au 136 de
réduction de la durée le portait de
l'investisseur ici de 6 à 3 ans et demi
et et pour la construction de 1 an et
demi pour la clôture de l'opération et
le transfert du bien de la csc y à
l'organisme de logement social alors
monsieur le rapporteur
oui c'est un sujet qui est récurrent
puisque on en a parlé tout à l'heure en
ce qui concerne l'impôt sur le revenu de
réduire les délais il nous paraît que le
conserver un délai de six ans pour nous
c'est une garantie de sérieux des
opérations et nous sommes donc
défavorable à l'amendement qui restent
alors deux avis défavorables
y at il une demande d'explication faute
qui est pour adopter cet amendement de
jacques gillot qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté deux amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune deux
amendements identiques gélita hoarau
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
actuellement les personnes physiques
éligibles aux dispositions de l'article
199 undecies a du code général des
impôts bénéficient d'une réduction
d'impôt majoré de 10% en cas
d'investissement dans les logements à
usage locatif situé dans certaines zones
urbaines des dom
il est proposé d'augmenter ce
pourcentage et l'amener à 25% et pouvoir
inciter à si les investissements dans le
logement ultramarins en outre
l'amendement proposé vise à majorer
l'avantagé fiscal accordé au titre de
l'article 217 and death y est lorsque
l'investissement porte sur certaines
certains logements à usage locatif situé
dans certaines zones sensibles à mayotte
merci merci et nous pinceau à l'examen
donc dû 331 chaque gillot s'est
elle-même
il est défendu monsieur le rapporteur
vous savez la parole est donc en ce qui
concerne ces deux amendements donc on a
une position légèrement différente de
celle qu'on avait sur les précédents
puisque si l'on n'est pas favorable à
l'augmentation des taux de
défiscalisation
nous souhaitons toutefois obtenir du
gouvernement un certain nombre
d'éclaircissements sur les raisons de la
différence de régime
entre la défiscalisation de l'impôt sur
le revenu et de l'impôt sur les sociétés
selanne à vis à vis du gouvernement est
défavorable à ces deux amendements mais
ils s'engagent à donner à la commission
dans les délais les problèmes les
éclaircissements qu'elle attend de sa
part donc sur la tenue de cet engagement
c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission qui est qui et pour adopter
cet amendement le 210 l331 qui est pour
et qui est contre
ces amendements ne sont pas adoptées
nous poursuivons deux amendements génie
terreur aux deux amendements proches
vous nous présenter le 209
en 6 min ce match et collègues pendant
l'article 217 indécis du code général
des impôts ne vise que la location
d'investissements productifs c'est à
dire la location d'immobilisation
affectés aux activités relevant des
secteurs éligibles en vertu des
dispositions du 1 de l'article 199
indécis et b du code général des impôts
il en résulte que seuls les schémas
locatifs réalisés au profit d'un
locataire exerçant une activité
éligibles défini par l'article 199
indécis et b du code général des impôts
peuvent bénéficier de la loi girardin
or dans un schéma de location ou sous
location portant ceux des logements
sociaux
le locataire offices hlm sem exercent
une activité immobilière expressément
exclue du secteur des activités
éligibles selon l'article 500 1,19 md
cb1 g du code général des impôts ce qui
devrait en principe rendre les schémas
de location ou sous location non
éligibles au dispositif de l'article 217
and death y ait du code général des
impôts l'objectif des présente
modification est de rendre les schémas
de sous-location éligibles au dispositif
girardin
à l'instar de ce que le projet de loi
prévoit pour les investisseurs
défiscalisables à l'impôt sur le revenu
qui finance l'acquisition ou la
construction de logements sociaux donné
en location nue à des offices hlm ou des
sem merci merci jacques gillot il est
défendu
monsieur le rapporteur sur les deux
amendements identiques on a une
proposition défavorable pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que le
dispositif de défiscalisation à l'impôt
sur le revenu est déjà très attractif
donc on ne voit pas pourquoi les tendres
ensuite c'est par la défiscalisation
l'impôt sur le revenu que se font déjà
la majorité des opérations de
défiscalisation
également le projet de loi prévoit
l'introduction d'un nouveau dispositif
de défiscalisation l'impôt sur les
sociétés qui vise le logement social et
enfin cette extension aurait un coût
supplémentaire pour les finances
publiques on a quatre raisons de
s'opposer aux deux amendements
est-ce que vous en avez 4 seule milice
de vous opposer au moins mais j'en ai
une cinquième c'est qu'il nous semble à
la lecture du de l'amendement et avec un
examen du code général des impôts c'est
que les programmes de logements visés
dans cet amendement sont déjà éligibles
donc il nous semble satisfait donc sous
nous souhaiterions qu'ils soient retirés
parce qu'il nous semble satisfait si ce
n'était pas le cas nous serions du même
avis que la commission c'est à dire nous
y opposerions un avis défavorable ce que
vous croyez monsieur le ministre
gélita hoarau roule maintenant bon les
deux amendements sont maintenus deux
avis défavorables qui est pour adopter
ces deux amendements très prochain
accord qui est contre ils ne sont pas
adoptées nous poursuivons avec deux
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune deux amendements
identiques alors vous souhaitez une
précision jean paul virapoullé
voilà et il en était de même pour daniel
marsin ils sont défendus quel est l'avis
de monsieur demi favorable monsieur me
voilà donc monsieur le rapporteur et le
ministre sont favorables l'assemblée est
favorable ils sont adoptés
merci gélita hoarau vous nous présenter
le deux sens
c'est le président de nice mes chers
collègues l'amendement proposé vise à
préciser pour les tomes les modalités
d'application du habitue à de l'article
217 mal des 6 du code général des impôts
seulement porter
cet amendement est en coordination avec
un amendement 209 des mêmes moteurs sur
lequel nous étions défavorable donc nous
sommes toujours défavorable logique avec
vous-même quoi excellent ministre aussi
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
adopter cet amendement qui est contre il
n'est pas adopté le 212 gélita hoarau
non je vais le faire je veux dire plus
il ya plusieurs revenir les îles allez-y
ok monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
actuellement la doctrine administrative
asept la taxation de la livraison à soi
même pour les constructions de logements
financés au moyen de prêts ou
subventions d'état régies par l'article
r 372 1 du code de la construction et de
l'habitation
cette condition pose problème dans les
schémas où la structure de financement
réunissant les vingt six investisseurs
et yes n'est pas le bénéficiaire direct
des ailes l'amendement proposé vise à
légaliser la troupe doctrine
administrative et à élargir dans les dom
le champ de la livraison à soi-même
taxable aux opérations de logements
sociaux conclut dans le cadre du
dispositif gironde
merci quel est l'avis de monsieur le
rapporteur bien l'avis de monsieur
rapporteur et l'avis de la commission
qu'il représentait donc comme nous
étions défavorable aux précédents qui
étaient en coordination avec
l'amendement 209 et qu'une partie de cet
amendement recouvre l'amendement de sang
neuf donc nous sommes défavorables
peut-être qu'il ya d'autres éléments
positifs dedans mais la partie 209 nous
fait rendre défavorable à cet amendement
monsieur le ministre il en est de même
monsieur le ministre qui est pour
adopter cet amendement qui est contre il
est adopté il n'est pas adopté pardon
le 213 gélita hoarau je vais continuer
sur la même lancée mais je prends aucune
réponse seront les mêmes la doctrine
administrative accorde le bénéfice du
taux réduit de tva aux seules
acquisitions ou construction de
logements financés au moyen de prêts aux
subventions d'état régi par lenticulaire
372 1 du code de la construction et de
l'habitation
cette condition pose problème dans les
schémas où la structure de financement
réunissant les investisseurs y ait ce
n'est pas bénéficiaire direct des aides
les amendements proposés ont pour objet
de légaliser la doctrine administrative
et d'élargir dans les dom le champ
d'application du taux réduit de tva aux
opérations de logements sociaux conclut
dans le cadre du dispositif gironde
alors la commission je pense que ces
mêmes points de vue et même région et
faillissent deux avis défavorables et je
crois que l'assemblée a la même position
c'est un avis défavorable il n'est pas
adopté nous avons deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
nous poursuivons deux amendements
identiques le 214 j'ai dit à aarau je le
retire au profit du destin 15 alors le
214 est retiré est ce que le 329 de
jacques gillot est maintenu et il est
retiré aussi donc le 329 est retiré
merci et nous passons aux deux ans que
215 donc nous avons là aussi la même
double être deux amendements identiques
de 100 cases et 330 chelito 1384 c du
code général des impôts dans sa
rédaction actuelle ne permet pas
l'exonération de taxe foncière
sur les propriétés bâties lorsque
l'acquéreur de logements sociaux stadia
office l'office hlm où la sem ne
bénéficient pas de prêts et subventions
régies par l'article r 372 1 du code de
construction et de l'habitation
l'amendement proposé a donc pour objet
d'étendre l'exonération de la taxe
foncière sur les propriétés bâties un
tel cas il précise aussi la durée
pendant laquelle aura lieu l'exonération
c'est à dire quinze ans alors ensuite
jacques gillot vous il est défendu
monsieur le rapporteur les deux
amendements qui viennent de nous est
présentée monsieur le président sont pas
en coordination avec deux amendements
précédent 209 et 326 conte à rejeter
l'eau bien évidemment on est défavorable
ici il en est de même et c'est la même
position notre assemblée
ça semble logique deux avis défavorables
à bonn les deux amendements ne sont pas
adoptées et nous terminons sur cet
article 20 par l'amendement 142 chaque
gillot lario orientations de la
défiscalisation vers le logement locatif
social et intermédiaire doit pouvoir
faire l'objet d'une évaluation partagée
avec les représentants des organismes de
logement social afin de définir les
adaptations utile et nécessaire et
favoriser les bonnes conditions de mise
en oeuvre des objectifs attendus du
dispositif
merci monsieur le rapporteur
je retrouve dans cet amendement comme
dans beaucoup d'autres amendements à
vouloir présenter un rapport comme
l'article 33 couvre cette proposition
donc on est défavorable à cet amendement
et on verra dans l'article 33 le contenu
du rapport que le ministre
deux avis défavorables c'est la même
position notre assemblée ce cet
amendement n'est pas adopté et l'article
20 ainsi amendé vous avez la parole
l'ancien ministre jean-pierre fourcade
merad
merci monsieur le président moi je
voulais avoir le vote sur cet article 20
dire deux choses d'abord que c'est un
article essentiel pour le redémarrage de
la construction de logements sociaux
dans les départements et territoires
d'outre-mer et qu' il montre vraiment
une volonté gouvernementale pour essayer
de répondre aux cent mille demandes de
logements qui sont actuellement déposés
et deuxièmement je voulais mettre à
profit cette très courte explication
pour remercier le ministre de la part
qu'il a prise à l'enrichissement du
texte il a suivi la commission
les commissions puisqu'il ya aussi la la
commission des affaires économiques et
la commission des lois dans la plupart
de leurs demandes il a fait preuve d'une
très grande ouverture d'esprit sur les
amendements et je crois que l'article 20
malgré ce grand nombre d'amendements
montre clairement que le sénat peut
enrichir un texte que nous propose le
gouvernement
odette terrade vous avez la parole oui
merci monsieur le président pour
expliquer notre vote sur l'affirmation
nécessaire de la priorité à la
réalisation de logements sociaux je ne
peux manquer d'apporter quelques
éléments complémentaires
s'il fallait se convaincre de la
nécessité de réaliser des logements
sociaux nous pourrions trouver trace
dans une entrevue accordée au quotidien
réunionnais témoignage par l'un des
responsables du principal opérateur de
logement social as it des erp ainsi est
il indiqué dans cette entrevue entre
autres je cite la principale qualité de
la mesure annoncée par le gouvernement
est de diminuer la pression sur le
foncier
parce qu'ils ne sont pas tenus de
respecter un couple à fond dans la
construction les promoteurs privés
enchérissent pour acheter un terrain
cela contribue à la flambée des prix du
foncier dit en substance le responsable
de la communication de l'acide dr or le
prix du foncier est un problème pour les
opérateurs du logement social car plus
le terrain aménagé cher - il reste de
crédit pour financer la construction ce
qui fait de l'existence du couple à fond
on traîne des appels d'offres
infructueux
car dans la situation actuelle les
entreprises du btp ont un plus grand
intérêt financier à travailler pour la
construction dans le secteur libre
soutenu par la défiscalisation la
stabilisation du prix du foncier peut
libérer de nouvelles marges de manoeuvre
et rendre le logement social plus
attractif car au final le coût d'un
logement social est le même que dans le
privé soit entre 2000 et deux semblent
et 2200 euros le mètre carré
fin de citation sans trahir la pensée de
cet observateur attentif de la réalité
locale
la même observation peut sans doute être
produites pour des systèmes le système
de robien mais là n'est pas le sujet et
médias la même analyse relève leur site
de nouveau au delà de ces aspects
financiers la réorientation de la
défiscalisation vers le logement social
permettra de définir une offre locative
plus en phase avec la réalité
réunionnaise
aujourd'hui on produit chaque année
entre 2000 à 3000 logements sociaux pour
environ 6000 logements défiscalisés dans
le secteur libre or les besoins sont
inverses
c'est à dire que 70% des familles
réunionnaises sont éligibles à un
logement social alors que les logements
soient construits grâce à la
défiscalisation ne s'adresse qu'à 20% de
la population
un des résultats de cette inadaptation
et le nombre croissant des demandes de
logement social
ils atteignent aujourd'hui bonne 5027
mille pardons selon la haye si dr la
défiscalisation du logement social
permettra donc peu à peu d'atteindre un
objectif de 6000 logements sociaux par
an mais sous plusieurs conditions
voilà donc cette dernière remarque vaut
évidemment pour les entreprises du
secteur du bâtiment qui craignent que
l'abandon progressif des opérations de
défiscalisation
pourtant sur les logements du secteur
locatif libre ou intermédiaire ne
conduise à un trou entre part entre
guillemets en termes d'activité qui ne
seraient pas suffisamment comblé par la
mise en oeuvre des programmes locatifs
sociaux en même temps l'exiguïté du
marché local notamment en matière de
demande de logements locatifs dit libre
ou intermédiaire rend de plus en plus
problématique le montage d'opérations de
ce type même dans le schéma actuel de
défiscalisation donc construire des
logements à loyer non encadrés grâce à
la défiscalisation qui demeurent vacants
n'est pas très intéressant pour une
société locale confrontés de manière
significative au problème du mal
logement
c'est ce que nous avions envie de
préciser avant cet article 20 merci des
tirades alors cet article 20
emblématique le plus important qui est
pour l'adopter genre jean claude frécon
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
malgré quelques amendements qui ont fait
l'objet d'un consensus dont
naturellement nous sommes satisfaits la
grèce très grande majorité des
amendements présentés par notre groupe
ont été rejetées ne d'autre part nous
constatons que si cette loi est prévu
pour des engagements sur une dizaine
d'années
l'engagement financier correspondant
n'est lui que les trois ans
qu'arrivera-t-il au bout de ces trois
ans donc en fonction de ceux-ci
le groupe socialiste ne votera pas cet
article 20 merci alors qui est pour
adopter cet article 20
et contre l'article 20 est adopté
abstention de gaston flosse c'est noté
je vous donne acte alors nous
poursuivons avec l'examen de
l'amendement 141 qui vise à insérer un
article additionnel après l'article 20
et c'est georges patient qui nous le
présente
vous avez quelques minutes pour
reclasser vos dossiers seconde monsieur
président d'accor
allez on va donner quelques zones de
respiration c'est le 141
c'est un article additionnel voilà
quand même beaucoup
monsieur le président merci de m'avoir
attendu que cet amendement propose
d'instaurer un dispositif de
défiscalisation au profit des
entreprises qui souhaiteraient acquérir
des terrains dans les départements
d'outre-mer en vue de leur aménagement
par les établissements publics fonciers
locaux et les fonds régionaux
d'aménagement foncier et urbains situés
dans les départements d'outre-mer afin
de répondre aux problèmes de logement
d'outre-mer par la constitution de
réserves foncières puis par leur
aménagement en vue de réaliser des
logements l'utilité des établissements
publics fonciers et leur nécessaire
développement ont été mises en avant et
spécialement préconisé dans un rapport
sénatorial de mai 2008
néanmoins ces établissements manquent
actuellement de moyens financiers pour
effectuer de telles opérations
or sans cette première étape
indispensable
aucun programme immobilier ne peut être
envisagée par conséquent cet amendement
propose de créer un dispositif de
défiscalisation permettant de contribuer
à l'acquisition par ces établissements
de terrain en vue de la construction de
logements sociaux ou de programmes
d'immobilier
conformément à l'article 199 un dossier
s'est modifié par le présent projet de
loi
merci bien quel est l'avis de monsieur
le rapporteur marc massion merci
monsieur le président sionisme et chaque
collègue la commission estime que le
problème de disponibilité de la
ressource foncière en outre-mer ne sera
pas réglée par l'augmentation des moyens
des établissements publics fonciers
bien que le rôle soit très utile il
conviendrait d'une part de créer des
établissements publics fonciers là où il
n'existe pas et d'autre part d'assurer
la participation des collectivités
territoriales à cette politique
le gip est mise en place un projet de
loi pour répondre aux problèmes de
l'indivision vise également remédier à
cette situation
enfin la commission ne souhaite pas la
multiplication des dispositifs de
défiscalisation outre mer
ce dispositif proposé parlement demande
étant d'ailleurs pas intégré au
plafonnement des niches fiscales donc
l'avis est défavorable
le seul ministre c'est le même avis y at
il des demandes d'explications de vote
ouais
allez jean etienne antoinette merci
monsieur le président je crois que tout
au long de cette excuse et nous avons
pointé du doigt la difficulté à financer
la viabilisation du foncier aménagé
c'est vrai pour toutes les régions
d'outre-mer et je veux citer l'exemple
de la guyane qui à l'établissement
public d'aménagement qui rencontrent des
difficultés financières
parce que le département est grand parce
que les besoins sont énormes et dès lors
qu'ils freinent la production de
logements sociaux
donc encore une fois nous avons dit que
bien que nous ne soyons pas favorable à
cette politique d'exonération de
défiscalisation par rapport aux effets
que nous avons déjà identifié mais
quelquefois il faut utiliser cet outil
justement pour compenser les mécanismes
qui ne fonctionne pas et selon nous
parce que nous sommes dans la première
phase de production de logements sociaux
il nous paraissait peut-être
fondamentale d'utiliser cet outil pour
s'inscrire dans un cercle vertueux de
vertueux pardon de production de
logements sociaux
c'était donc ça un peu l'esprit de cet
amendement qui est pour adopter cet
amendement qui est pour et qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté
nous poursuivons jean paul virapoullé
267 monsieur le président tout seul
ministre chers collègues tout le monde a
compris que la politique de logement
outre-mer était un au centre de nos
préoccupations
le logement c'est un facteur de cohésion
sociale de paix sociale de justice
sociale et il a été à l'origine le
manque de logement social est l'un des
facteurs qui justifient qui explique pas
qu'ils justifient qui explique
l'explosion sociale qui a lieu outre-mer
aider à ce point du débat je voudrais
apporter tout mon soutien au
gouvernement d'avoir eu le courage je
dis bien le courage d'orienter l'argent
de la défiscalisation vers le social et
c'est à mon avis un choix stratégique
dont mesureront les effets au fil des
années à venir
alors pourquoi je présente un amendement
pour répondre à ce que disait notre
collègue communiste à leurs intervenants
et citant les statistiques à la réunion
c'est que si on prend la loi girardin
on a fait plus d'intermédiaires
spéculatifs alors que dans les quatre
départements d'outre-mer
nous avons un besoin extraordinairement
important dans le domaine du très social
financé essentiellement par la haine
mais u et du social intermédiaire
financé par personne et par aucun
système parce que vous avez les gens
très pauvres et vous avez les gens
pauvres entre les très pauvres et la
classe moyenne et un éventail un arc en
ciel mon amendement il se situe dans la
droite ligne de la volonté politique du
gouvernement de dire oui à la solidarité
sans dépenser plus mais en dépensant
mieux
et je propose donc par la rédaction de
cet amendement à l'ensemble de nos
collègues
c'est pour ça que j'interviens un petit
peu longuement de mettre en oeuvre un
intermédiaire sociale et le gouvernement
devra fixer par décret le montant des
revenus qui auront droit à ce logement
ainsi que le prix du loyer au mètre
carré de tordre de telle sorte qu'il n'y
ait plus le très social l'intermédiaire
défiscalisées et je partage des analyses
qui ont été faites et rien au milieu
avec cet amendement nous allons créer la
séquence sociale qui manque dans le
logement au niveau des conséquences du
vote de cet amendement c'est pas une
dépense en plus c'est une dépense mieux
orienté c'est l'industrie du bâtiment
qui est la première industrie deux des
quatre départements comme l'automobile
chez vous si en période de crise
internationale nationale et
départementale nous rajoutons une crise
sur le logement c'est pas l'explosion de
la guadeloupe que nous allons vivre dans
les semaines qui viennent
c'est une méga explosion dans les quatre
départements d'outre-mer
l'industrie du bâtiment a plusieurs
effets il est facteur de cohésion parce
qu'il permet aux familles de vivre
correctement
il est facteur d'emplois parce que chez
nous à la réunion ces vingt mille
emplois dont 10000 dans le seul secteur
du logement et ça doit être identique au
point de vue pourcentage dans les autres
dom
alors mes chers collègues je vous
propose
j'allais dire en votre âme et conscience
de bien réfléchir avant de donner votre
avis de voter cet amendement
si vous le faites vous aurez posé la
première pierre d'une réorientation
d'une refondation de la solidarité entre
la métropole et l'outre-mer ne pas
dépenser plus mais dépenser mieux
ne pas augmenter le débit
obligatoirement mais réguler le débit
vers ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
voilà pourquoi je compte sur la
sincérité l'objectivité et le soutien de
chacun d'entre vous pour mettre en
oeuvre ce que moi j'appelle le jégo
social il ya eu le girardin spéculatifs
mais je préfère le jégo sociale parce
que le gigot social il va aller vers les
plus pauvres
ma alors est ce que vous êtes pour le
jégo sociale ou la commission alors
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'avis de la commission c'est la
première étape et c'est souvent l'étape
la plus difficile à franchir monsieur
virapoullé apparaît que l'outre-mer mais
des fils ira déjà du dispositif de
défiscalisation du logement social et
intermédiaire mis en place pour
l'article 20 d'autre part que les effets
pervers important des dispositifs de
défiscalisation actuellement appliquée à
votre mère ont été dénoncées par la
commission des finances à de multiples
reprises
enfin il n'est pas justifié de prévoir
une réduction d'impôt majoré spécifiques
à l'outre-mer pour le dispositif
scellier dans une première étape puis
vous reste de l'espoir monsieur
virapoullé avis défavorable a alors me
ce ministre et bien messieurs mesdames
et messieurs le gouvernement a proposé
une période transitoire pour la
défiscalisation patrimoniale du logement
locatif intermédiaire plus longue que
celle ouverte pour le logement libre je
le disais tout à l'heure puisque votre
commission des finances a prolongé d'une
année dispositif qui ira jusqu'au 31
décembre 2013 c'est déjà un point qui de
nos débats l'amendement
qui nous est présenté par jean paul
virapoullé pour sa part s'appuie sur un
dispositif de défiscalisation de
temporaire conçu pour faire face à la
crise économique qui frappe en premier
lieu le secteur du bâtiment et des
travaux publics
c'est donc un objectif de relance qu on
ne peut que partager évidemment au delà
de l'objectif
nous souscrivons également à la cible
visée par cet amendement
à l'heure actuelle le logement
intermédiaire défiscalisé à des plafonds
de loyer qui nous sommes trop élevées de
l'ordre de 12 euros le mètre carré
de plus ces logements intermédiaires
peuvent être loués que six ans ces
logements comme vous le relevez monsieur
le sénateur ne sont pas assez sociaux
c'est d'ailleurs le sens de l'extinction
progressive au bénéfice des programmes
mixtes qui vient d'être débattue on est
vraiment dans la cohérence de ce que
nous avons décidé avec cet amendement
nous pourrions donc cibler très
directement les ménages qui peuvent
payer un loyer
un peu supérieur au plafond des
logements sociaux de l'ordre de 8 à 10
euros le mètre carré
en plus ces logements qui doivent être
loués 9 voire au delà
et cela avec un avantage fiscal
complémentaire il s'agit donc d'un
véritable produit social utile nous
semble-t-il complément en période de
crise économique
au programme mixte que proposait le
gouvernement l'idée que vous évoquez
d'une palette la plus large possible
d'outils nous sommes correspondent à ce
qui était d'ailleurs demandé de part et
d'autre de l'assemblée
évidemment comme la défiscalisation est
appliqué sur une période plus longue en
plus elle serait très tactique très
attractive pour beaucoup plus de ménages
et le gouvernement vous l'avez compris
partage donc votre objectif est le
principe de votre amendement
il est cependant nécessaire évidemment
de mesurer les conditions de succès de
ce nouvel outil qui seraient ainsi créés
si vous proposez de l'appeler jégo
sociale rend encore plus difficile toute
critique trop forte notamment par
rapport à la défiscalisation patrimonial
sur le logement intermédiaire prolongée'
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut voir comment la
ne va pas vampiriser l'autre jusqu'au 31
décembre 2013 donc comme un travail d
expertise et il faut également éviter
que ce tout nouvel outil ne prive les
programmes mixtes de ressources de la
défiscalisation là aussi les moyens de
la défiscalisation ne sont pas infinies
ils iront vers les dispositifs les plus
avantageux il ne faut pas qu'en créant
un dispositif supplémentaire
on ne prive les autres programmes des
ressources 10 de la défiscalisation
aussi le gouvernement va laisser à
l'assemblée la sagesse de sa décision
mais si cet amendement est adopté
eh bien nous serons amenés à l'assemblée
nationale dans la lecture du test à du
texte a proposé évidemment les
ajustements nécessaires aux dispositifs
tels que ils ont été évoqués par dans
votre intervention le gage élevé si je
comprends bien
si le si l'amendement est adopté
évidemment bon monsieur le président de
la commission des finances
ce président c'est maylis mais chaque
année que nous avons une discussion qui
est très intéressant très constructive
et je pense que nous avançons dans la
bonne direction pour favoriser le
développement économique de l'outre-mer
choix salué la créativité de jean paul
virapoullé et la force de conviction qui
l'animé qu'il parvient souvent à faire
partager moi je suis très très sensible
et je suis obligé
me prémunir contre les assauts de jean
paul virapoullé jouer simplement vous
rappeler mes chers collègues que dans le
collectif budgétaire qui sera examiné
dans maintenant trois semaines nous en
serons à 104 105 milliards de déficit
public non compris le déficit probable
de la sécurité sociale c'est à dire que
seront au delà de 120 milliards de
déficit
non je crois qu'il faut vraiment que
nous soyons prudents la loi scellier
nous l'avons revisité à l'occasion du
collectif budgétaire de fin d'année 2008
pour substituer aux dispositifs robien
et à quelques autres des mesures plus
ciblées sait si bien ciblé que des
projets d'arrêtés du ministre du budget
et du ministre du logement créé des
troubles considérable dans nombre de
départements métropolitains 25%
ce sera pour les territoires et qui
auront été reconnus par le gouvernement
et vous vous dites voilà pour
l'outre-mer ça va être 40%
je pense que franchement c'est excessif
nous avons voté un ensemble de
dispositions fiscalement coûteuse dont
qui affectent directement l'équilibré
des finances publiques
et en ce qui me concerne je le vis comme
un déchirement jean-paul je ne voterai
pas fatras montant alors un avis
défavorable de la commission
une sagesse positif du gouvernement et
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances vient de dire qu'il ne
voterait pas cet amendement alors je
soumets
jean pierre fourcade vous avez la parole
la position de monsieur le président de
la commission des finances est une
position que je respecte profondément et
il a raison de dire que chaque fois
qu'on discute d'un texte dans cet
hémicycle on rajoute des éléments en
déficit mais je voudrais reprendre ce
qu'a dit le ministre tout à l'heure le
ministre a reconnu que l'amendement de
notre collègue monsieur virapoullé
ajoute dans la palette des propositions
des offres qui seront faites au
demandeur demandeurs de logement en
créant enfin un financement pour le
logement intermédiaire mais le ministre
a dit tout à l'heure que il laissait
l'assemblée voté selon la sagesse
habituel quitte à ce que dans le débat à
l'assemblée nationale
on a juste un petit peu et je crois que
monsieur virapoullé accepte qu'on puisse
ajuster soit les taux soient les
modalités soient les délais de manière
arriver à quelque chose qui soit sur le
plan social intéressant et sur le plan
financier pas trop coûteux dans ces
conditions le groupe ump votera
l'amendement de monsieur virapoullé
alors les choses sont claires qui est
pour adopter limbes en 267 qui est
l'amant demande de monsieur virapoullé
pied contre un alors
trois contes qui s'abstient cas voilà eh
bien écoutez cet amendement est adopté
alors seul président je n'ai pas entendu
alors nous avons deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
c'est georges patient qui nous présente
le 143 l'article 15 29 du code général
des impôts permet aux communes qui le
souhaitent d'instaurer une taxation pour
percevoir une partie de la plus value
générée par l'ouverture de terrains à
l'urbanisation le présent amendement
vise à autoriser les communes ill et
établissements publics de coopération
internationale
les opci pardon qui le souhaitent à
majorer le montant de cette taxe dans le
taux pourrait ainsi varier entre 10 et
15%
merci gélita hoarau vous nous présenter
le 216 ce président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
cet amendement d'un autre groupe hot sur
la question de la taxation des plus
values foncières réalisées par les
propriétaires c'est dans des terrains à
vocation agricole pour les transformer
en terrains à bâtir
on se souviendra que l'article 1529 du
code général des impôts avait été
modifié par la loi de finances
rectificative en 2006 après que le débat
eut été ouvert par l'une les lois borloo
en l'occurrence la loi portant
engagement national pour le logement
ce dispositif permet aux collectivités
locales de récupérer une partie du
produit de la vente de ces terrains
devenus constructibles terrain qui dans
un contexte de rareté de cherté du
foncier disponible peuvent parfois être
particulièrement valorisé le produit de
cette taxe est pour le moment
infinitésimale faut-il le souligner ne
serait ce d'ailleurs que pour une seule
raison c'est que sa principale vertu et
d'être dissuasives en effet assorti d'un
certain nombre de dispositifs
dérogatoires la taxe eux à son corps
défendant conduire les cédants a
pratiqué par eux mêmes une réduction des
prix de vente
ainsi la taxe s'applique
ne s'applique pas je cite petite aoc
sion mentionné au troisième à 8e 2 de
l'article 158 c'est-à-dire aux sessions
concernant les terrains vendus pour un
faible montant destiné à construire des
logements sociaux ou encore expropriés
pour raisons d'utilité publique par
exemple tibet aux cessions portant sur
des terrains qui sont placés en terrains
constructibles depuis plus de 18 ans
petit c'est lorsque le prix de cession
du terrain définie à l'article 150 vea
est inférieur au prix d'acquisition
effectivement acquittés par le cédant
est tel qu il a été stipulé dans l'acte
de cession majoré d'un montant égal à
200 poissons de ce prix ce qui constitue
une minoration du coût du foncier fin de
citation dans les faits la taxe est donc
une forte incitation à la réalisation de
logements sociaux et à utilisation du
foncier disponible à cet usage
et bien c'est sa tête deux objectifs que
nous poursuivons avec cet amendement de
notre groupe il s'agit de rendre plus
coûteux en apparence les opérations des
cessions de terrains nus des loques
cetera ne seront pas affectés à la
réalisation de logements sociaux ou pour
le moins de programmes comportant une
part significative de logements sociaux
c'est donc sous le bénéfice de ces
observations que nous vous invitons
adopté cet amendement merci merci gélita
hoarau alors quel est l'avis de monsieur
le commissaire c'est le rapporteur
pentue le commissaire le ch est le
président chez les minimes et chers
collègues les deux amendements sont très
proches l'un de l'autre
on l'a déjà dit la commission n'est pas
favorable a priori à l'augmentation de
la pression fiscale portant sur les
cessions de terrains
elle relève toutefois que cette
majoration sera laissée à la libre
appréciation des collectivités
territoriales concernées souhaitent donc
obtenir l'avis du gouvernement ce
ministre
écoutez le gouvernement souhaite
privilégier l'application des textes
actuels qui permettent déjà une
procédure de taxation sur la base d'une
volonté des conseils municipaux ou
constate qu'il est d'ailleurs très peu
de communes qui ont mis en place pour
l'instant ce dispositif
donc de ce fait dans l'espoir que le
dispositif existant déjà soit utilisée
il est défavorable la création d'un
dispositif complémentaire bien vous
rallier à cet avis monsieur le
rapporteur
donc avis défavorable de la commission
qui est pour adopter ces deux
amendements très proches et pour qui et
contre ils ne sont pas adoptées nous
passons à l'examen de l'article 20 bis
et plus particulièrement de l'amendement
231 présenté par gaston flosse le
plafonnement rendrait difficile sinon
impossible financement des gros
investissements structurants comme les
hôtels où le câble souterrain sous
marins et aboutira à réduire de manière
considérable le montant global de
financement au profit du développement
des collectivités d'outre-mer un moment
où leur talent de ces dernières par
rapport à la métropole est rappelé de
manière brutale et inquiétante et où la
crise prend des proportions sans commune
mesure avec ce qu'elle est en france
continentale
il paraît légitime de ne pas interrompre
ou affaiblir le seul mécanisme qui
permet de développer les économies de
nos collectivités
cependant si nous souhaitons tous la
disparition pure et simple du
plafonnement
on peut comprendre les préoccupations du
gouvernement il est proposé donc de
différer son application jusqu'à la
sortie de la crise en tout état de cause
les réflexions initiées par le président
la république dans le cadre d'états
généraux de l'outre-mer
deux volets permet d'identifier de
nouvelles pistes de développement et il
serait inopportun de préjugés merci
qu'ils aient la vie de monsieur le
rapporteur sur le président sur le
ministre et chaque collègue l'avis de la
commission est défavorable à cet
amendement n'est fait et contraire à la
position de la commission des finances
sur le plafonnement des niches fiscales
ministre mais ma vie qui est pour
adopter cet amendement pour qui et
contre il n'est pas adopté et l'article
20 bis est adopté en l'état il est
adopté en l'état nous passons à l'examen
de l'article 20 terre et nous avons
quatre moments qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
deux amendements identiques le 333
rectifier et c'est georges patient qui
nous présente cet amendement de
suppression
c'est un amendement visant à supprimer
l'obligation d'information de toute
opération de défiscalisation auprès des
collectivités au territoire yal celle ci
dispose déjà de nombreux moyens
d'information et de possibilité de
donner leur avis sur de telles
investissement cette obligation n'a que
pour seule finalité d'alourdir ou de
rallonger le processus c'est monsieur le
ministre c'est le même oui c'est un
amendement qui est qui est similaire à
celui qui est prêt à proposer bercy
propose d'ailleurs de retirer au profit
de l'amendement parlementaire alors le
412 et retiré au profit du 333 rectifié
de georges patient et puis michel magras
vous présenter le sang je suis le
président il me semble que si
l'amendement 445 rectifié de la
commission des finances qui va être
incessamment débattu et voilà il me
semble qu'ils donnent entière
satisfaction à l'amendement que j'avais
dix-huit déposé je le retire est retiré
et maintenant c'est le 445 rectifier
alors c'est le président de la
commission des finances qu'il présente
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
l'amendement que nous avons déposée au
nom de la commission des finances sur
l'article 20 ter réécrit cet article il
retient bien sûr le principe de la
consultation des collectivités
territoriales
les conseils régionaux pour les
départements lorsque nous avons des des
régions mono-départementales
l'assemblée territoriale pour wallis et
futuna
le conseil général de mayotte les
conseils territoriaux de saint pierre et
miquelon saint barthélemy et saint
martin et le congrès de la nouvelle
calédonie ainsi que celui de l'assemblée
de la polynésie française donc nous
retenons le principe de la consultation
bien sûr et puisque nous avons eu à
examiner des amendements tendant à
restreindre la défiscalisation sur
certains types d'activités et nos amis
de saint-barthélemy et de saint-martin
était porteur de ces amendements
ce qui tend à réduire le champ de la
défiscalisation parce que les
responsables d'un territoire peuvent
considérer que tel type de
défiscalisation encourage le
développement d'activités et qui
deviennent en quelque sorte parasitaire
à l'égard à l'encontre du développement
local
ça peut être l'encombrement de bateaux
parce qu'au bout de cinq ans plus
personne n'utilise et certains ports
sont saturés ça peut être la saturation
des parkings saint martin ou à saint
barthélemy parce que on défiscalise des
quantités considérables de voitures
destinées à la location qui ne
correspond pas au marché donc il nous
paraît important alors que la loi a
défini un cadre général de
défiscalisation de permettre aux
autorités locales dans délibéré et de
décider que tel type d'activité ne sera
pas éligibles à la défiscalisation
nous pensons qu'il serait bon que dans
les six mois qui suivront la
promulgation de la loi
nous sommes en train de discuter
l'assemblée puissant délibérer si elle
entend imposer des restrictions et que
les révisions
de ces restrictions puisse être
prononcée au lendemain du renouvellement
de ces assemblées dans les six mois qui
suivent le renouvellement de l'assemblée
tel est l'objet de cet amendement et qui
pour une fois monsieur le ministre est
de nature à éviter de dégrader le
déficit public alors maintenant nous en
venons à l'examen donc le 333 rectifié
monsieur le rapporteur
c'était la suppression de cet article
si on fait le 412 a été retiré le son un
a été retiré et le 333 ne qui est
maintenu mais s'il georges patient vous
le retirez le 333 au bo bénéfice de
l'amendement présenté par monsieur
arthuis a retiré la logique voudrait qu
il ait retiré le 333 rectifier et je
soumets à l'approbation alors quel est
votre avis bien sûr sur le 445 celle que
président qui vient de le dire qu'elle
est levée le gouvernement quelle est
votre position
alors dans un souci d'équilibré
le gouvernement qui tout à l'heure à
donner à une sagesse favorable
à l'amendement de jean paul virapoullé
et
et tenter effectivement de laisser la
sagesse à l'assemblée sur cet amendement
qui vient d'être déposée qui nécessite
quand même une petite expertise
juridique pour voir dans quelles
conditions chacune des collectivités
pour l appliquer sous réserve de cette
expertise qui pourrait si l'assemblée
adopte cet amendement et nous amener à
leur retouché à l'assemblée nationale
nous laissons donc une sagesse positive
à l'assemblée et si j'osais avec un peu
d'humour en cette fin de journée nous
levons le gage non perçue récupérable à
vous laisser faire cela monsieur arthuis
ah ouais
non mais écoutez monsieur monsieur
arthuis me mets toujours l'impression
qu'on prenait pour une fois je peux
manger bon a les pieds pour adopter cet
amendement avec la sagesse positif du
gouvernement qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté et l'article 21
ainsi amendé est adoptée dans les mêmes
conditions il est adopté l'article 21 je
n'ai pas de demande de parole ni
d'abonnement il est adoptée dans les
mêmes conditions il est adopté et nous
passons à l'examen de l'article 22
j'ai une demande de parole de serge
larcher monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues régis
cet article quand on vise à permettre
les classements la cession par l'état
des personnes physiques ou morales des
terrains situés dans la zone des 50 pas
géométriques
c'est très important je peux même loué
la volonté de monsieur le ministre vous
a libéré ces terrains pour permettre la
construction mesure et de logement
social mais il faudrait monsieur me
disent qu'ils y mettent un certain
nombre de garde-fous à particulier
éviter que notre littoral de soin d'eux
devient trop bétonné parce qu'il revient
aux antilles on vient aux antilles on
n'est pas ailleurs je ne fais pas
d'appel je ne fais pas de comparaison
avec quelques banlieue pour le port est
probant qui que ce soit mais il faut
sauvegarder le caractère authentique des
antilles même s'ils ont une
préoccupation de loger les habitants des
nos deux départements
alors ceci étant dit il ya notre souci
c'est qu'il faut permettre là
libre accès des personnes à la plage
c'est très importante cela il faut en
faisant cela monsieur monsieur le
ministre vous allez hop véritablement
avec ce conte ce que nous avons dit
pendant le début du débat avec cette
tradition se trouve vous allez faire la
rupture avec l'histoire postcoloniale
nous avons hérité de cette situation de
fait et vous avez de belles demeures
avec des noms parc qui longe nounou
plachez et deux accès à la mer
permettent à monsieur vous allez dire
monsieur tartempion nous disons à martic
monsieur dix ans on lui permettre
d'aller à la plage avec sa famille sans
déranger qui que ce soit sans provoquer
qui que ce soit mais passé la journée au
bord de la mer je serai très à l'avancé
et je crois que l'ensemble des
martiniquais et des guadeloupéens
d'aigus pas des guyanais et des
martiniquais réunionnais et l'aiguillât
ne pouvoir pas saluerait cette
initiative mais encore au coffre de thil
avoir la volonté d'imposer cela parce
que il demeure tout de même chez nous
certaines féodalité pour ne pas dire
plus il faut venir c'est que je remercie
monsieur le ministre de nous montrer par
votre action
votre volonté de faire de résoudre
briser cet héritage du passé
merci merci serge larcher nous avons
deux amendements alors un premier
amendement de suppression de l'article
qui est présentée de 70 par odette
terrade
merci monsieur le président se présente
article ajoute un article code de la
propriété des personnes publiques visant
à permettre la cession à titre onéreux
delà des personnes physiques ou morales
les terrains libres de toute occupation
situé dans la zone des 50 pas
géométriques
cette zone a été reclassé dans le
domaine public maritime de l'état en
1986 dans la loi littoral inaliénable et
imprescriptible
cette disposition a été assouplie en
1996 introduisant la possibilité de
cession soit à titre gratuit aux
communes aux organismes d'habitation
call soit titre onéreux aux particuliers
des seuls terrains situés dans les
espaces urbains et des secteurs occupés
par une urbanisation diffuse au sein de
cette zone
ces mesures selon les rapporteurs de la
commission des finances ne sont pas
encore assez souple il abonde dans le
sens de cet article pour les assouplir
encore au nom d'une action nécessaire
face aux blocages rencontrés pour en
finir avec les dents creuses pour mettre
fin aux lourdeurs administratives ne
permettant pas de faire ce que l'on veut
sur le littoral au nom de la nécessaire
actions ont choisi une solution rapide
et à courte vue permettre un peu plus
les opérations immobilières sur le
littoral et réduire un peu plus le
contrôle de l'état sur cette zone
la solution proposée ici selon nous
pourraient être pires que le problème
lui-même cette disposition tient comme
un fait inamovible que l'état ne peut
rien faire pour réhabiliter cette zone
des 50 pas qu'il n'a pas les moyens et
donc prône de passer la patate chaude si
je puis dire au domaine privé
eh bien nous prétendons que si les
moyens nécessaires été donnée aux
offices publics
nous pourrions réhabiliter cette zone en
faire des logements sociaux et préserver
le littoral des dispositions saurait
dans ce cadre certainement nécessaires
pour doter les office d'outil adéquat
mais certainement pas celle ce qui nous
est proposé ici c'est à dire un abandon
pu en abandon pur et simple des
principes qui a conduit à la loi
littoral pour serrer sont mes chers
collègues et pour ce que vient de dire
notre collègue avant moi sur la
nécessité aussi de permettre à la plage
et de permettre la circulation
nous vous demandons de voter notre
amendement de suppression
merci alors jean paul virapoullé
donc c'est marc massion qui nous
présente l'amendement 244 c'est un
amendement qui est présentée par
monsieur virapoullé au nom de la
commission des lois
l'article 22 autorisa pas déclassement
du domaine public la cession à titre
onéreux à toute personne physique ou
morale de terrain inoccupé situé dans la
zone des 50 pas géométriques
cet amendement tend à autoriser ce
déclassement dès lors que les autres
mme susceptibles de bénéficier de la
cession gratuite n'ont pas demandé cette
session dans un délai de six mois à
compter d'une mise en demeure adressée
par l'autorité administrative compétente
il sécurise ainsi le dispositif et
permet de faciliter les opérations de
déclassement il a semblé à la commission
que la modification rédactionnelle part
effectivement de nature à améliorer
l'efficacité du dispositif
en ce qui concerne l'amendement 70
l'article 22 adoptée par la commission
des finances vise à favoriser l'exercice
des missions des agences des 50 pas
géométriques en élargissant les
possibilités de cessions de terrains qui
ne trouvent pas acquéreur dans la
situation actuelle il ne nous semble pas
opportun de supprimer cet article
donc avis défavorable et une seule
ministre sur l'amendement 70
effectivement nous ne sommes pas
favorables à sa suppression va ce serait
quand même une drôle de position
consistant à dire qu'il ya un problème
sur les cinquante pages aux métriques
depuis des années malheur on ne change
rien au contraire nous souhaitons par
cet amendement par cet article bien
permettent justement une évolution je
rassure chacun des intervenants il
s'agit de préserver tous les éléments de
patrimoine l'accès aux plages de faire
en sorte que des à certain nombre de
villes et de communes puissent étendre
les quartiers qu'elle puisse utiliser ce
qui est aujourd'hui des dents creuses
que tout le monde dénonce moi j'ai vu de
nombreux maires qui me disent mais il
faudrait qu'on puisse y arriver c'est
bien un objectif très protecteur que
nous voulons mettre derrière cette
volonté du gouvernement très en phase
avec les agences des 50 pas géométriques
et très positif à la fois pour la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
qualité de ces secteurs
mais pour sortir aussi comme ça a été
dit tout à l'heure d'une période
ancienne qui voulait que ses terres et
un statut particulier donc je vous
rassure sur cet aspect et nous sommes
défavorable à la suppression parce que
nous avons une vision positive de
l'action que nous voulons mener quand
l'amendement 244 virapoullé repris par
monsieur mention le sommes évidemment
très mation bardon nous sommes très
favorables
alors y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote sur l'amendement
de suppression qui est pour l'adopter
pour qui et contre il n'est pas adoptée
et avis favorable de l'amendement de la
commission le 244 qui est pour l'adopter
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté et l'article 22 ainsi amendé est
adoptée dans les mêmes conditions
l'article 23 je n'ai pas de demande de
parole ni d'abonnement
il est adopté il en est de même pour le
24 il est adopté il en est de même pour
le 25 il est adopté et nous passons à
l'examen de l'amendement 255 c'est
jacques gillot qui nous présente
monsieur le président la crise qu'ils
traversent ces dernières années le
secteur du logement social a pour
conséquence une dégradation des
conditions de logement et le regain de
l'habitat insalubre
sur l'ensemble des régions et des
collectivités d'outre-mer comme
l'indiquent le rapport du sénateur henri
tort cette situation appelle une
véritable politique de lutte contre
l'habitat indigne avec une programmation
la hauteur du défi de cet enjeu de
cohésion sociale et de dignité des
populations concernées
la mise en oeuvre du droit au logement
opposable en outre-mer n'aura de sens
dans son application
que ce défaut conséquent de l'état en
étroite relation avec les collectivités
et conduit de façon significative et
durable dans ce domaine merci quel est
l'avis de monsieur le rapporteur
je suis le président tchèque mis mes
chers collègues
cet amendement nous semble purement
déclaratoire l'état met déjà en oeuvre
en partenariat avec les collectivités
territoriales d'outre-mer une politique
de résorption de l'habitat insalubre
donc avis défavorable le ministre oui
évidemment c'est pour nous une action
importante à la lutte contre l'habitat
insalubre et l'habitat indigne
d'ailleurs le gouvernement j'ai confié
une mission à serge letchimy député
maire de fort de france qui connaît bien
ce sujet qui a commencé son travail et
qui va nous proposer plus d'ailleurs que
un programme mais une un plan d'action
complet sur ce sujet donc je suggère aux
sénateurs auteurs de cet amendement
qu'il le retire puisque nous reviendrons
avec les résultats de la mission
letchimy 255 et retirer le 312 c'est
notre collègue robert lauf à oulu qui
nous le présente le président cet
amendement vise à étendre à wallis et
futuna le bénéfice du prêt à taux zéro
en utilisant les structures dépendant de
l'état comme l' agence française de
développement actuellement au lycée
futuna l'afd et la bwf banque privée
filiale bnp paribas ce sont les seuls
établissements autorisés à pratiquer des
prêts l'afd a jusqu'à il y a quelques
années pratiqué dans des divers lieux où
elle est implantée des prêts aux
particuliers pour l'acquisition d'un
logement
c'est qu'il ne fait plus aujourd'hui il
serait bon qu'elle puisse remplir ce
rôle tout comme éventuellement d'autres
structures à wallis et futuna où les
ménages les moins aisés sont dans
l'impossibilité de construire leur
logement l'état doit et plus et la mise
en place du prêt à taux zéro pour ce
ménage de wallis et futuna
je suis conscient qu'il existe à wallis
et futuna une difficulté liée à
l'absence de garantie foncière
mais me semble impératif de trouver un
système permettant aux petits salariés
de construire ou acquérir leur logement
comme monnaie de ménage en métropole une
relance du fonds de garantie à l'habitat
il n'a pas bien fonctionné par manque de
suivi à l'afd pourrait répondre à ce
besoin
je suis sûr que les contrôles sérieux
que la présente loi se propose mettre en
place garantirai la pérennité d'un tel
dispositif
merci quel est l'avis de monsieur le
rapporteur le président c'est le mini
michel collet comme le l'amendement
précédent cet amendement nous paraît
purement déclaratoire sur le fond la
commission juge qu'il appartient au
gouvernement de préciser sa politique en
matière de logement à wallis et futuna
avis défavorable ce ministre oui pour
m'être rendu monsieur le sénateur
récemment à wallis et futuna et je
mesure évidemment l'enjeu que représente
la politique du logement pour votre
territoire
mais vous le savez c'est la collectivité
qui à wallis et futuna détient les
compétences pour le logement il lui
appartient donc de décider des outils
les mieux adaptés pour favoriser
l'accessibilité sociale et la propriété
des ménages
je vais demander là sans délai à
l'administrateur supérieur de wallis et
futuna d'apporter son concours technique
à la collectivité pour établir de façon
précise des besoins en logement tant
plan quantitatif que qualitatif et
mettre notre expertise à sa disposition
pour les outils à mettre en oeuvre
sous cette réserve là je pense que
plutôt que de donner un avis défavorable
il serait raisonnable de retirer votre
demande
il est il est maintenu ou retirer les
attirer bon le l'amendement 312 est
retiré vous venez de suivre l'examen du
projet de loi relatifs au développement
économique de l'outre-mer je vous
rappelle que ce texte a été adopté hier
soir par les sénateurs vous pourrez
revoir cette séance sur notre site
internet www.publicsenat.fr
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt sur public sénat